Ryan: Welcome everyone.
It is my pleasure today to introduce
two time Grammy nominated
singer, songwriter, producer
Eric Roberson to perform
as part of our Musicians@Google series.
Eric's released seven albums
on his label called 'Blue Arrow Soul'.
It's an independent label
which he started in 2001.
In '07, he was the first Indie artist
to be nominated for a BET Award.
His most recent album,
'Music Fan First', has two songs
which were nominated for Grammys
including the song 'Still'
which was nominated for the upcoming
awards in February.
Eric's been a force in the music industry
for over 15 years
and has worked with and written
for artists ranging from DJ Jazzy Jeff,
Will Smith, Jill Scott, Music Soul Child,
and many more.
On a more personal note,
whenever I make heartbreak mixes
Eric's songs are right in there
when my friends or myself
are goin' through that.
His songs deal with that topic
and many more.
He's a great story teller, a wonderful lyricist,
and genuinely a great guy.
So please join me in welcoming Eric Roberson.
[applause]
Eric Roberson: Hi everybody.
I 'm Eric Roberson and I'm going
to name the band behind me.
And right now, as we speak,
we're gonna call them
"The Bomb Dot Com".
So Eric Roberson featuring
The Bomb Dot Com. [laughs]
Aaron Hardin: Wow.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: That's a good one.
Eric "Rain Man" Gaston:  Thank you, thank you.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklkn:  Appreciate that.
[drummer begins playing]
So I have seven albums.
We'll talk more about
that as we keep going on.
But this song is entitled 'Newness'.
Eric Roberson: I might feel like standin' up.
We gotta fill it up.
[drummer playing]
[slow easy music]
♪ Well I guess I'm just caught up
in the newness ♪
♪ But truth be told I think she is the one ♪
♪ Even though I know
it's just the newness ♪
♪ It's just the newness ♪
♪ (newness) ♪
♪ It's just ♪
♪ Don't know what tomorrow holds ♪
♪ (no) ♪
♪ But I hope she's holdin' on ♪
♪ From this point on yeah ♪
♪ (yeah) ♪
♪ Ever since she signed onboard ♪
♪ We been goin' hard ♪
♪ (so hard) ♪
♪ Til like 8:45 ♪
♪ (a.m.) ♪
♪ Now I'm at my 9 to 5 ♪
♪ (asleep) ♪
♪ But never feelin' so alive yeah ♪
♪ I guess you can blame
my brand new friend ♪
♪ Since she entered ♪
♪ I been holdin' her more than my pen ♪
♪ And you know that's a lot ♪
♪ First time I ever got writer's block ♪
♪ Okay maybe not 'cause when we part ♪
♪ The pen just won't stop ♪
♪ No ♪
♪ (hey) ♪
♪ Well I guess I'm just caught up
in the newness ♪
♪ But truth be told I think she is the one ♪
♪ Even though I know it's just the newness ♪
♪ It's just the newness ♪
♪ (newness) ♪
♪ It's just ♪
♪ We act like we're still nineteen ♪
♪ (oh, oh) ♪
♪ And every time we kiss ♪
♪ It's like a movie scene yeah ♪
(yeah)
♪ Oh from that Love Jones flick ♪
♪ You play Nia Long ♪
♪ (that's you) ♪
♪ I play Lorenz Tate ♪
♪ (that's me) ♪
♪ You come downstairs
with them legs ♪
♪ I'm makin' cheese omelets, girl ♪
♪ Okay I digress I'm just havin' fun ♪
♪ (yeah) ♪
♪ Serious love is so over done yeah ♪
♪ (Let's pick it up yeah) ♪
♪ It's just fresh like a lotion ♪
♪ That you just rubbed on ♪
♪ (yeah) ♪
♪ I be layin' on my pillow ♪
♪ When she's gone ♪
♪ (yeah) ♪
♪ Be layin' there like man come on ♪
♪ When you comin' back girl? ♪
♪ (Well I guess I'm just caught up
in the newness) ♪
♪ Caught up in the newness yeah ♪
♪ (But truth be told I think she's the one) ♪
♪ The one ♪
♪ (I know) ♪
♪ I know ♪
♪ Come on I know ♪
♪ (It's just the newness) ♪
♪ (It's just) ♪
♪ Do ya remember the first time ♪
♪ You heard a hip-hop song? ♪
♪ (hey) ♪
♪ Or the first time you spent all night ♪
♪ Talkin' on the phone? ♪
♪ 'Member how that felt? ♪
♪ When you wrote your first rhyme ♪
♪ (Yeah) ♪
♪ Remember how that felt? ♪
Well it's called the newness
But you already knew this
Don't hear me rhyme
But I just had to loop this
Man, it's the lovin'
She's sitting at the oven
Making me some waffles
she's trying to get the title
More than likely she probably be wifey
If she gotta have it,
then hell I'm Spike Lee
And I'm there nightly
I'm a midnight marauder
Matter of fact got a text,
Just said to call her
If I had the money, man,
I would just spoil her
So I give her kisses
And treat her like the missus, man
Take her out on the town
Night do the runnin' man
Kid n play, do the wop,
til all the music stop
Go off to IHOP,
talk in the parking lot
No oh here some the cops
tellin' us to scram
Damn, I just grab her hand,
let's go
Here we go, DMC and this little fan
In the van, in the van,
We on the road again
And ah man,
I was 'bout to finish up the story
Chick got me more whipped
than Denzel in 'Glory'
Brett called me up like,
'Yo your girlie's on Maury'
Guess that's poor me
♪ (yeah) ♪
♪ Guess that's poor me ♪
♪ (oh, oh) ♪
♪ Til the newness comes hey ♪
♪ Well I guess I'm just caught up
in the newness ♪
♪ But truth be told I think
she is the one ♪
♪ Even though I know
it's just the newness ♪
♪ It's just the newness ♪
♪ Break it down for me ♪
So listen.
Ones who do not know who I am.
My name is Eric Roberson.
It is a pleasure to be here.
I've had a tour of your amazing establishment
and I'm filling out an application immediately--
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Yes.
Eric Roberson: I'm tryin' to start
the Music Keep Us All Happy Department.
I'm just gonna come to each person's
office with the harmonica
and just sing about whatever
you're doing right now you know.
[laughs]
♪ You didn't have to wear a suit today ♪
Ooh
You know what I mean.
And ah but it's amazing.
It feels beautiful, and we are taking notes.
Before we go any further,
please make some noise for my
amazing staff who's sprinkled out
throughout here and --
[applause]
we're a small company.
We don't make, we don't gross
as much as Google makes.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: [laughs]
Eric Roberson: We may not gross
as much as--
never mind I won't finish that sentence.
We're taping.
I don't need the IRS to Google me.
But anyway um, no but ah
we wanna just talk about love
'cause we received a lot of love here.
And it is that new love,
that-that fresh love,
that I can't stop thinking about you love,
that what there's free beer
in a room kinda love, you know.
That I wanna talk to you
all night long kinda love,
that my oh my cell phone is dying
that's me calling on my house phone
click over kinda love.
She knows about that see.
I know I would get the girl in the corner.
She knows about.
But we wanna just talk about that.
It's the newness love and
we show so much love here
and we just wanna have a good time.
Some of you may know who I am.
Some of you may not.
Most of you probably don't.
But we're gonna include all you guys anyway.
The next song that we're about to do
is entitled 'Borrow You'
and it's a--
it's a fun little ditty.
And if you want to borrow someone
in the room, now is your opportunity.
And it goes like this.
♪ [slow instrumental music]
♪ yeah ♪
♪ ta, ta, ta, dum ♪
♪ ta, ta, ta, ta, ta ♪
♪ yeah ♪
♪ ta, ta, ta, dum ♪
♪ ta, ta, ta, ta, ta ♪
♪ I see you with your girls ♪
♪ And I truly do apologize ♪
♪ Yes I really realize ♪
♪ You're not here for these dudes ♪
♪ I see that big ring on your hand ♪
♪ And trust me, girl, I understand ♪
♪ Back at home you got a man ♪
♪ And that's not the way I move ♪
♪ But when the DJ threw this record on ♪
♪ I saw you throw up both your arms, ♪
♪ Close your eyes and sing along ♪
♪ Guess you like this tune ♪
♪ And your legs can't stay still at all ♪
♪ Those high heel shoes you took 'em off ♪
♪ So let me escort you to the floor girl, ♪
♪ Can I borrow you? ♪
♪ Maybe he wouldn't mind ♪
♪ If for a song or two, ♪
♪ You can act like your mine. ♪
♪ Oh can I borrow you girl? ♪
♪ Would that be ok? ♪
♪ Maybe when the song is done ♪
♪ You could just walk ♪
♪ And I'll watch you as you go ♪
♪ (hey walk away) ♪
♪ As you
(walk away) ♪
♪ Hey I watch you as you go baby ♪
♪ (walk away) ♪
♪ As you
(walk away) ♪
♪ As you Hey ♪
♪ I'm fully focused on your sway ♪
♪ And really into what you say. ♪
♪ I can't hear you anyway. ♪
♪ Your smile says it all. ♪
♪ Ah now you wanna turn around. ♪
♪ Well I'm not gonna fight you now. ♪
♪ I'm not here to slow you down. ♪
♪ No
(oh no, no, no, no) ♪
♪ See I'm just here to compliment ♪
♪ Your style in any way I fit. ♪
♪ Can I get close a little bit? ♪
♪ I'm feeling it. ♪
♪ Consider it ♪
♪ A gift for you to just enjoy. ♪
♪ I wish that I could give you more ♪
♪ But I guess that's not
what we're here for. ♪
♪ No ♪
♪ Can I borrow you? ♪
(hey)
♪ Maybe he wouldn't mind ♪
♪ If for a song or two ♪
♪ You can act like your mine. ♪
♪ Oh, can I borrow you, girl? ♪
♪ Would that be okay? ♪
♪ Maybe when the song is done, ♪
♪ you could just walk
(walk away) ♪
♪ And I watch you as you go ♪
♪ (walk away ) ♪
♪ As you
(walk away) ♪
♪ I watch you as you go.
Oh yeah. ♪
♪ (walk away) ♪
♪ As you
(walk away) ♪
♪ As you yeah ♪
♪ We had some fun. ♪
♪ I find it
(special) ♪
♪ I'm so
(careful) ♪
♪ Not to let my heart ♪
♪ (talk right now baby) ♪
♪ 'Cause you'll get
(an earful) ♪
♪ Of me slick talkin'
(of this limited time) ♪
♪ For I enjoyed you bein' mine ♪
♪ Can I borrow you?
(yeah) ♪
♪ Maybe he wouldn't mind
(maybe he wouldn't mind) ♪
♪ If for a song or two
(if for a song or two) ♪
♪ You can act like your mine
(you can act like your mine) ♪
♪ Oh can I borrow you? ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, baby
(would that be ok) ♪
♪ Would that be okay?
(maybe when the song is done) ♪
♪ Maybe when the song is done
(you can just walk away) ♪
♪ You can just ♪
♪ Can I borrow you, baby?
(maybe he wouldn't mind) ♪
♪ Maybe he wouldn't mind.
(if for a song or two) ♪
♪ If for a song or two
(you can act like you're mine) ♪
♪ You can act like you're mine
(oh, can I borrow you, girl?) ♪
♪ Oh no, no, no, no, baby.
(would that be okay) ♪
♪ Would that be okay?
(maybe when the song is done) ♪
♪ Maybe girl ♪
♪ You can just walk away ♪
♪ I watch you as you just
(walk away) ♪
♪ Ooh, you're lookin' good, baby. ♪
♪ Just
(walk away) ♪
♪ Before I say
♪ Something ♪
♪ I shouldn't say ♪
♪ Babe ♪♪
♪ [instrumental music]
Eric Roberson: So my story was
I was a songwriter producer.
I've written songs for everybody
and their mother.
Ryan told you about some of them.
I wasn't happy with
where my career was at.
Sure I was okay financially,
but I had all these songs
I wasn't willing to sell.
And-- and I started making a album
as a hobby.
And I really was willing to just sell it
to whoever wanted to buy it.
If I sold two copies,
I would have been fine.
And my fans that I gained,
all seven of them,
challenged me to-- to take things serious
and to do more music.
And the amazing thing is
that we made another album.
And-- and now we're on
now album number seven.
And we've had the fortunate opportunity
to have toured the world several times over.
We've done Russia.
We've done Japan, and all over Europe,
everywhere you can possibly imagine
as well as all over the United States.
And recently, from a company
that we manufacture,
distribute all of our music ourselves
with distribution deals in other countries,
we were nominated for a Grammy which
you know is unheard of in R&B music,
two years straight.
Thank you very much.
Alright.
The beer hasn't got to them yet.
[laughs]
But it's been a blessing.
And It's --
I'm sure a lot of people here
can relate.
When you just follow your heart,
a lot of rewards can happen
and it's very important that
we all be honest with ourselves
and we ask ourselves honest questions
and give ourselves honest answers.
So, with that said,
I would like to dedicate this next song
to the young lady whose
middle name is [Lavet].
She didn't want everyone
to know that here --
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Wow!
Eric Roberson: --but it's my personal
pleasure of letting the cat out of the bag.
So when you see her tag
and it just says "L",
you know that it's 'Lavet'.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Wow.
Eric Roberson: This song is entitled
'Pretty Girl'.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: He's in rare
form ladies and gentlemen,
rare form.
Aaron Hardin: Rare form, rare form.
Eric Roberson: Did someone
put anything in these almonds?
♪ [music]
Eric Roberson: A little faster.
♪ badaaaaa,badaaa ♪
♪ ooooo oooooo ooo ♪
♪ badadadada ♪
♪ Pretty girl ♪
♪ Do you always use your smile ♪
♪ To get your way? ♪
♪ Once in a while ♪
♪ Do you use your heart?
(Use your heart) ♪
♪ Do find that hard to do, pretty girl? ♪
♪ Ooh ooh
♪ Were you hurt by love before? ♪
♪ Too much pain for
your heart to ignore. ♪
♪ Is it why you hide
(Why you hide) ♪
♪ Behind a disguise? ♪
♪ Ooh yeah ♪
♪ Pretty girl oooh ♪
♪ One day you're gonna wake up
and find out ♪
♪ That a time cannot rewind ♪
♪ While you're out chasin' things ♪
♪ Seems like you're flyin' right
past your dreams yeah. ♪
♪ But I wanna know
who you really are pretty girl. ♪
♪ One day you're gonna
wake up and find out ♪
♪ That a time cannot rewind ♪
♪ While you're out chasin' things ♪
♪ Seems like you're flyin' right
past your dreams yeah. ♪
♪ I wanna know who you really are
pretty girl yeah. ♪
♪ (yeah) ♪
♪ Trust in me. ♪
♪ There's no need to run. ♪
♪ So be yourself
and what you want to become. ♪
♪ You can rest assured.
(You can rest assured) ♪
♪ It ain't just your
(It ain't just your) ♪
♪ Beauty that's gonna get you through, ♪
♪ Just doin what the others do. ♪
♪ When there's love happenin' for you. ♪
♪ Oh yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ One day you're gonna wake up
and find out that a time cannot rewind. ♪
♪ While you're out chasin' things, ♪
♪ Seems like you're flyin' right
past your dreams yeah. ♪
♪ But I wanna know ♪
♪ Who you really are pretty girl. ♪
♪ One day you're gonna wake up
and find out ♪
♪ That a time cannot rewind. ♪
♪ While you're out chasin' things. ♪
♪ Seems like you're flyin' right
past your dreams, yeah. ♪
♪ I wanna know who you really are. ♪
(hey)
♪ A rose can't bloom
(A rose can't bloom) ♪
♪ Before its time.
(Before its time) ♪
♪ But it will never bloom
(But it will never bloom) ♪
♪ If the sun don't shine.
(If the sun don't shine) ♪
♪ So live your life.
(So live your life) ♪
♪ No need to hide,
(No need to hide) ♪
♪ Girl, what's inside.
(Girl what's inside) ♪
♪ 'Cause that's not right.
('Cause that ain't right) ♪
♪ You'll see what's true.
(You'll see what's true) ♪
♪ What's there for you yeah
(What's there for you) ♪
♪ Loves you for you
(Loves you for you, girl) ♪
♪ Stop playin' games though.
(Stop playin' games) ♪
♪ Now you might lose
(Now you might lose ) ♪
♪ A friend or two.
(A friend or two) ♪
♪ But if you do,
(But if you do) ♪
♪ They ain't there for you
(Are they really there for you) ♪
♪ Ask yourself, Baby
(baby) ♪
♪ You need to see. Yeah
(You need to see) ♪
♪ Open your eyes. Yeah
(Open your eyes) ♪
♪ And realize Yeah
(And realize) ♪
♪ That you're worth more.
(That you're worth more) ♪
♪ My pretty girl,
(My pretty girl) ♪
♪ I'm pretty sure
(I'm pretty sure) ♪
♪ You're worth much more Hey
(You're worth much more) ♪
♪ So, so much more Yeah
(So, so much more) ♪
♪ So, so much more
♪ So, so much more Yeah
(So, so much more) ♪
♪ So much more Yeah
♪ So, so much more Yeah
(So, so much more) ♪
♪ So, so much more
♪ So, so much more Yeah
(So, so much more) ♪
♪ You're worth much more ♪
♪ So, so much more
(So, so much more) ♪
So, so much more
Yeah
[applause]
Eric Roberson: Thank you very much.
Now, since I would safely say 90% of you
in here may not know these songs,
I figure out let's do
something really special.
Let's-- let's maybe make a song up that
we can all learn and know together.
Yes.
So what we're gonna do
is we're going to --
D. Maurice "DMo" Mackline: Yeah,
they were excited about that.
Eric Roberson: They were--
they were really, really but let's,
we're gonna treat it fairly you know.
I'm sure you're very happy
with your jobs.
But let me first say real quick one of my
favorite songwriters in the entire world,
very, very amazing, amazing songwriter
has written songs
for everybody and their mother is in
the room right here Gordon Chambers.
He's in the black jacket.
Wave your hand, Gordon.
[applause]
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Alright.
Eric Roberson: Amazing, amazing
artist, singer, songwriter.
And one of the reasons
when I started selling songs,
it was because I read an article
about this young man
and said this can actually,
I can pay rent by doing this.
So followed in his footsteps.
So in the theme of
writing songs, you know,
we're going to write this song
together right now.
And we're gonna share the publishing.
All of us, every single person
in this room.
We're gonna split it up evenly.
Like 83%  on the stage here and 17 --
well, we'll let the finance people
take care of all that stuff.
But what I need is this.
I need subjects from the crowd.
It could be literally anything you want
but let it not be anything like love --
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Please make it
difficult for him.
Eric Roberson: -or peace or, you know,like don't-
don't like just, don't make it a simple song.
A song is only as good as the words given.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Yes.
Eric Roberson: So we have one hand up.
Yes
audience: [inaudible]
Eric Roberson: Okay, alright.
Trying to get some brownie
points on the day.
What's your name?
audience: [inaudible]
Eric Roberson: Mike Gavin.
It's Mike Gavin's birthday.
Okay, that's one subject.
Mike Gavin's birthday.
Okay, thank you.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Algorithm?
Eric Roberson: Mike Gavin, stop.
Yes, Gordon.
Search engines.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Yes.
Eric Roberson: Thank you,
that's-that's --
Yes.
audience: Legos.
Eric Roberson: Legos.
Eric Roberson: Thank you, so we got,
we have Mike Garvin's birthday?
Mike Gavin: Gavin.
Eric Roberson: Mike Gavin, that's right.
I'm gonna mess it up several times
and I'm gonna sing about
how I'm gonna mess it up too,
but Mike Gavin's birthday.
Mind, could I tell how old you are,
Mike Gavin?
Eric Roberson: Thirty-one.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Woo-hoo. Wow.
[drum roll]
Eric Roberson: The three one.
Make some noise for Mike Gavin.
[applause and cheering]
Eric Roberson: Search engines.
Legos.
Do we have one more?
Let's get one more.
audience: [inaudible]
Eric Roberson: Vegetari-ism.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Vegetarianism.
Eric Roberson: Vegetarianism.
Thank you very, God bless you.
What's your name?
audience: [inaudible]
Eric Roberson: Wi-wi. Uh-oh.
What's that?
audience: And liquor.
Eric Roberson: And liquor. Let --
we'll end it with liquor. Okay.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Yeah.
Eric "Rain Man" Gaston: Yes.
Eric Roberson: Vegetarianism --
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: That's my favorite
subject.
Eric Roberson: liquor, search engines, Legos--
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: And Mike Gavin.
Eric Roberson: and Mike Gavin's birthday.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Get drunk.
Eric Roberson: We're gonna make
this entire thing up including the music.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: on Mike Gavin's
birthday.
Eric Robeson: So make some noise
for the band one time.
Eric "Rain Man" Gaston: Yeah.
[applause]
Eric Roberson: The Bomb Dot Com.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: The Bomb Dot Com.
Pick it up.
Eric Roberson: And we're gonna
add Google into it of course
because I want them
to sponsor my next tour.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: [laughs]
Eric Roberson: Aaron, Aaron Hardin on keys.
Aaron can you-- can you play something
that represents Legos and liquor?
Aaron Hardin: Legos and liquor. Yeah
that's a good combination right there.
I've done some amazing things
with Legos and liquor.
[playing keyboard]
Eric Roberson: Yeah.
I like that. I like that.
You could give me the--
you can give me the search engine feel
you know side of it.
So we have vegetarianism.
We have liquor, Legos,
search engines,
and Mike Gavin's birthday
who is turning 31.
Okay. Alright.
Eric Roberson: Yeah.
[keyboard, drum, and sticks being played]
Eric Roberson: Give me a little smooth out..
There you go.
♪ If I wanna show a girl that
I'm full with wisdom ♪
♪ that I know about liquor
and vegetarianism, yeah ♪
♪ And also I heard Mike Gavin
is havin' a party for his birthday ♪
♪ But I didn't get a flyer ♪
♪ So don't nearly know my way ♪
♪ I go to my Apple
and go to a search engine. ♪
♪ Because I need to find
which street his party is on. ♪
♪ And when I walk in,
he may be surprised ♪
♪ 'cause he didn't give me a invitation. ♪
♪ But I'm like Google
helped me find Mike Gavin. ♪
♪ Happy Birthday
(Happy Birthday) ♪
♪ You're 31
(31) ♪
♪ I looked on Google
how to make this drink. ♪
♪ We gonna have some fun.
(gonna have some fun) ♪
♪ Mike Gavin
(Mike Gavin) ♪
♪ is turnin' 31
(turnin' 31) ♪
♪ I put up liquor
in the Google search engine. ♪
♪ We gonna have fun. ♪
Check it out
♪ (gonna get crazy drunk yeah) ♪
♪ I met this girl other day in Harlem. ♪
Ooh
♪ I tapped her on the shoulder. ♪
♪ I said, 'Beg your pardon. ♪
♪ Would you like to go to dinner sometime?' ♪
♪ She said, 'Well, okay.
But keep in mind ♪
♪ I don't eat pork, or beef, or red meat,
or chicken or turkey.' ♪
I said, 'Whoa, whoa, whoa.
[laughter]
Do you eat?'
She said, 'Yes.'
I said, 'Okay then I guess
♪ you can come to my house and
maybe I can make you some food.' ♪
♪ Don't know how that even left my breath ♪
♪ because I'm really not even a chef. ♪
♪ So now I'm really scared to death. ♪
♪ What can I make for this girl? ♪
♪ So I turn on my laptop ♪
♪ and went to Google.com ♪
♪ because I didn't get any advice
from my mom. ♪
♪ She said, 'If you ain't roastin' no turkey, ♪
♪ then I can't help you at all.' ♪
♪ So I guess Google search engine
is once again I call ♪
♪ because I said ♪
♪ She said, 'Ooh, um, um.
This is delicious.' ♪
♪ I said, When it comes to vegetarianism,
I'm vicious.' ♪
[laughter]
♪ I searched Google so I can find
vegetarian dishes ♪
♪ so I can quench her vegetarianism wishes. ♪
Yeah.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: [laughs]
♪ So and also I do not drink. ♪
♪ But sometimes I may think that
I can do anything that I can imagine. ♪
♪ So I wanna share a little secret
in here about my idea, ♪
♪ Outside of singin',
I have this passion to take Legos ♪
♪ (take Legos) ♪
♪ and build me a big ol' bed.
(yeah) ♪
♪ Take Legos
(Legos) ♪
♪ And maybe sleep in that instead.
(oh yeah) ♪
♪ Take Legos.
(Legos) ♪
♪ But don't want it to collapse
and break my head. ♪
♪ (not your head no) ♪
♪ So I go to Google.com
(yeah) ♪
♪ let me tell ya 'bout what I read. ♪
It said,
♪ 'Take the big pieces first ♪
♪ and put it at the bottom
(at the bottom yeah) ♪
♪ 'cause if you start with small pieces first ♪
♪ You'll have a hell of a problem. ♪
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: [laughing]
♪ 'cause you can really sleep
with the big ones ♪
♪ closer to your dome. ♪
♪ So if I got in my big ol' Lego bed, ♪
♪ I felt somethin' would be so wrong. ♪
(hey)
♪ Ain't that right Mark Garvin ♪
♪ Mike Garvin
(Gavin) ♪
♪ 'cause he just turned 31.
(31) ♪
♪ I told you I would mess up his name
(yes you did) ♪
♪ but hell we're just havin' fun. ♪
(yeah, yeah) ♪
♪ Hey ain't that right Mike Gardy
(Mike Gravin) ♪
♪ I just thought that would be cool.
(yeah) ♪
♪ This building is really big.
(yeah, yeah) ♪
♪ It really felt like a Google school. ♪
♪ Thank you Pam for givin' me a tour
(yeah) ♪
♪ as well as all of my staff. ♪
(thank you)
♪ And your jokes was cool. ♪
(yeah)
♪ And you noticed that all of us laughed
(uh-huh) ♪
♪ and it wasn't 'cause just the liquor. ♪
♪ (no) ♪
♪ nor because it's Garvin's birthday.
(no, no) ♪
♪ We have a few more things that
I would really just like to say. ♪
♪ I love how the furniture
(yeah) ♪
♪ is colorful ♪
♪ like a set of logos, Legos. ♪
♪ You have a kitchen with almonds, ♪
♪ refrigerator has Eggos. ♪
♪ But I mean it's really cool. ♪
♪ I would even be a janitor. ♪
♪ I would work here immediately. ♪
♪ A bigger job I would prefer. ♪
♪ Maybe yours. ♪
♪ Excuse me.
I'm really just havin' fun. ♪
♪ See and I think all of the words are done. ♪
♪ So let me know
if everyone is having fun. ♪
♪ (yeah, yeah) ♪
♪ This was a brand new Google song.♪
♪ that's done by every [inaudible] son ♪♪
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Let's get
chocolate wasted, y'all.
Eric Roberson: Thank you very much.
So listen.
I wanna invite a young lady up on stage,
amazing singer who came
to town to perform.
I do a free show, not a free show.
I'm wilding right now, not free show.
I do a show every third Wednesday at
SOV's in New York called Soul Village.
It's an amazing, amazing fun show
we've been doing
for over seven years
and her as well as DMo.
Come on. Come on.
They're a group called Duacity
and they performed last night.
But I have a song I did with a young
lady named Lalah Hathaway.
If you don't know who she is,
you can Google her name.
And-- and we wanna do that song
for you right now.
And I would love for Candice
to sing the song with me,
and I'm gonna--
I'm gonna sing it.
I'm sorry I've been callin' her Candice
but I had too much Gatorade to drink.
Her name is actually Claudia.
[laughter]
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: He's messin' up
everybody's names today.
Eric Roberson: For the rest of the day
she'll be called Lavet.
We're just gonna call her Lavet.
Make some noise for Lavet.
[applause]
No. That's the true Lavet.
I know that's right.
Lavet say "I'm gonna claim
my middle name back." No --
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Wow.
Eric Roberson: So let's start it.
And by a raise of hands,
how many people have ever dealt with somebody
you shouldn't have been dealing with?
Just-- okay.
We got--
alright, alright.
Okay.
Alright.
Claudia: Check, check.
Eric Roberson: Well, this song dedicated
to the man in the blue--
gray shirt, grayish blue shirt.
Claudia: Check, check.
Eric Roberson: Alright. Aaron.
Yes.
♪ [slow music]
Eric Roberson: Hey.
You have your tag on.
I don't have my tag on.
Claudia: You should have your tag on.
Eric Roberson: I may get arrested.
Let's start it right here.
♪ Where do we go from here? ♪
♪ What must I do with these feelings? ♪
♪ (what) ♪
♪ Yearning to have you near. ♪
♪ Know when we shouldn't be dealing. ♪
♪ (why) ♪
♪ Why must the bad things
always feel so good? ♪
♪ Why can't I just stay away? ♪
♪ Thought our situation was understood. ♪
♪ Still does not mean it's okay.
(No, no) ♪
♪ Where do we go from here? ♪
♪ What must I do with these feelings? ♪
♪ I do not know. ♪
♪ Yearning to have you near. ♪
Know when we shouldn't be dealing
Claudia everything
♪ Oh, oh, oh. ♪
♪ Why must these memories
I can't erase them? ♪
♪ Why I yearn for your kiss ♪
♪ From the moment we're not face to face? ♪
♪ Reminds me how much you miss. ♪
♪ So where do we go?
(where do we do from here?) ♪
♪ Oh no. ♪
♪ (What must I do with these feelings?) ♪
♪ Oh, no, oh. ♪
♪ Yearning to have you near. ♪
♪ Know when we shouldn't be dealing. ♪
♪ When the morning comes, ♪
♪ When it's time for us
to go our separate ways, ♪
♪ Oooh the sun. ♪
♪ Oh I'll be wanting to hold onto you.
Yeah. ♪
♪ Ooooh the sun. ♪
♪ Wish we could push it all away. ♪
♪ 'Cause then I'll know that we can show
what we have from today. ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. ♪
♪ What must I do with these feelings? ♪
♪ I don't know what do
with these feelings. ♪
♪ I need to have you near. ♪
♪ Oh. ♪
♪ Know when we shouldn't be dealing. ♪
♪ Break it down.
Break it down. ♪
♪ (Where do we go from here?) ♪
♪ Maybe if I'm patient, then one day
it would change (yeaaaah) ♪
♪ I'll wake up in the morning and
it will not be the same, no. ♪
♪ Every day is different.  ♪
♪ We just up and
play the same ol' game ♪
Yeah.
♪ Play the same. ♪
♪ Where do we go?
(go from here) ♪
♪ What must I do with these feelings? ♪
♪ Yearning to have you near. ♪
♪ Know when we shouldn't be dealing. ♪
Eric Roberson: Make some noise
for Claudia, y'all.
[applause]
Thank you, aka Candice, aka Lavet.
Claudia: Right, right, right.
Eric Roberson: Praise God.
[applause]
So we're gonna do one more.
But we have a mailing list
passing around.
I think I saw you guys signing it.
Even without my glasses
I noticed that.
And we may even have some CD's.
Once again,
I wanna just thank, first of all my
dear friend Sweet Locks and Ryan
for establishing the relationship
to put this together.
[applause]
We really, really have a great time.
And this song is entitled
'Could Not Hear Me Over the Muzak'.
Oh, what's that?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Lavet is gonna cut us.
We gotta cut, go back.
We're gonna do 'Still'
and then, right, right.
The boss has spoken.
I'm sorry.
How dare I not show you
the set list before we--
[slow gentle music]
♪ Missing ♪
♪ Yearning ♪
♪ Tossing ♪
♪ Turning ♪
♪ Fiending ♪
♪ For her still,♪
♪ Waiting ♪
♪ Shaking ♪
♪ Hating ♪
♪ Having ♪
♪ Flashbacks ♪
♪ Asking ♪
♪ Why me? ♪
♪ Blindly ♪
♪ Walking ♪
♪ Hoping ♪
♪ Praying ♪
♪ That she ♪
♪ Finds me ♪
♪ Sees me ♪
♪ Wants me ♪
♪ Needs me ♪
♪ Still ♪
♪ By her side ♪
(hey)
♪ I've been fine ♪
♪ But tonight was tough
(oh) ♪
♪ Heard our song.
(yeah) ♪
♪ My heart had enough ♪
♪ Finish my drink ♪
♪ I hug my friends ♪
♪ They all look concerned ♪
♪ I smiled at them ♪
♪ I said that I'm fine ♪
♪ But that is a lie ♪
♪ One I hide behind ♪
♪ She is on my mind ♪
♪ Outside is cold ♪
♪ And damn these cabs ♪
♪ I need one really bad ♪
♪ But they all pass ♪
♪ Memories ♪
♪ They just creep back in.
(yeah) ♪
♪ I zone out on
♪ Remember whens ♪
♪ A cab cuts through
and I hop on in ♪
♪ 'Just drive man, drive.' ♪
♪ Is all I say to him.
Oh ♪
♪ She still can hurt me from so far away ♪
♪ (still hurt me from so far) ♪
♪ Still reaches in and
pulls my smile away ♪
♪ (reaches in my dream) ♪
♪ Just when I'm fine ♪
♪ She still finds a simple way ♪
♪ (in another smile) ♪
♪ To show her goodbyes ♪
♪ In another way ♪
♪ (oohhhh) ♪
♪ Oh No No No No No ♪
♪ (oh no, no, no, no, no) ♪
♪ No No No No No ♪
♪ I do not understand ♪
♪ Why I miss her still. ♪
♪ I try to escape ♪
♪ But nothing works ♪
♪ (oh) ♪
♪ We did everything together.
(yeah) ♪
♪ Now everything hurts
(hurts) ♪
♪ We pass the store ♪
♪ that we used to shop ♪
♪ Favorite park.
(yeah) ♪
♪ First restaurant.
♪ This corner is fine ♪
♪ I will walk from here.
(yeah) ♪
♪ I could use the air
♪ She won't disappear ♪
♪ Truth hits me like the midnight wind ♪
♪ A stranger smiles ♪
♪ It's hard to grin ♪
♪ See ♪
♪ My mask is off.
(yeah) ♪
♪ Familiar streets I cross
♪ As if I am lost ♪
♪ I guess I am. ♪
♪ I can't find my way. ♪
♪ Even home
(home) ♪
♪ Feels like an empty place
Oh ♪
♪ She still can hurt me from so far away
(still hurt me from so far)
♪ Still reaches in and
pulls me time away ♪
♪ (reaches in my dream) ♪
♪ Just when I'm fine ♪
♪ She still finds a simple way
(and another smile) ♪
♪ To show her goodbyes
(hey hey oh no no no no no) ♪
♪ In another way.
Oh No No No No No (oooh oooh) ♪
♪ No No No No No
(No No No No Nuh- nuh NO) ♪
Oh No No No No No
(oohhh hooohhh oh)
♪ I can't, I can't.
I can't take it, baby ♪
♪ Oh No No No No No ♪
♪ No No No No No ♪
♪ I do not understand ♪
♪ Why I miss her still ♪
♪ Missing ♪
♪ Yearning
(oh no) ♪
♪ Tossing
(no, no no) ♪
♪ Turning ♪
♪ Waiting ♪
♪ Shaking ♪
♪ Fiending
(fiending for her STILL) ♪
♪ Hating ♪
♪ Having ♪
♪ Flashbacks ♪
♪ Asking ♪
♪ (Why she's not comin' back) ♪
♪ I do not understand ♪
♪ Why I miss her still ♪
♪ Walking ♪
♪ Down this lonely road ♪
♪ I'm just praying for ♪
♪ [inaudible] before ♪
♪ To a song to ignore ♪
♪ What my heart is for ♪
♪ So with memories
of my summer breeze ♪
♪ I don't understand
(I miss her still) ♪
♪ Want her
(still) ♪
♪ Miss her
♪ Need her
(still) ♪
♪ Oh no, no, no, no, no, no ♪
♪ Need to know ♪
♪ Why I can't let go.
(let it go) ♪
♪ Miss her so
(miss her so) ♪
♪ Still ♪♪
[applause]
Eric Robeson: Yes.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate that.
So you know also for some
who have seen the video.
We shot the video for that last year
and it is really a video we did
to promote cancer awareness.
And once again,
I want to shout out my staff who helped me
put the entire video together as well.
[applause]
We really appreciate that.
With that said --
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: So proud.
Eric Roberson: --with that said.
Thank you, Garvin.
Gavin.
Gavin, can I sing happy birthday
to you?
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Wow,
she is dictating a lot now.
Eric Roberson: You know what?
Lavet is just taking control.
I think we're gonna add you
to the staff as the--
--okay. Okay. Alright.
[clears throat]
We're gonna sing it
in a manly way though--
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: [laughs]
Eric Roberson: Mike. Is there any
other birthdays here?
Any other?
Any other birthdays?
Okay. So there's just me and you, Mike.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Wow. [laughs]
Right. Pause.
Eric Roberson: But let me get focused.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: It's just me
and you Mike.
Eric Roberson: 'Cause Mike, you know
you're in a great age.
Thirty-one is amazing 'cause now
you're getting set into your 30's.
It's great.
♪ Hap- ♪
You're soundin' really good today, Aaron.
♪ py birthday to you ♪
I think he blew me a kiss.
Let me get my--
[laughter]
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: [laughter]
Happy birthday to you.
[clapping and cheering]
We're not done yet. Okay. Alright.
I appreciate that. [clears throat]
[singing]
♪ Happy birthday!!!! ♪
>>D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Make some noise.
[applause]
♪ dear -- ♪
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Please.
Dammit.
[laughter]
My God.
♪ Mike Gavin who's turning 31 ♪
♪ Happy, happy, yeah. ♪
I don't know anything about
Pentecostal churches but --
♪ Happy, happy
(happy yeah) ♪
♪ birthday to-- ♪
♪ --to you. ♪
[drums]
Eric Roberson: Make some noise
for Mike Gastineau.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Gavin. [laughter]
Eric Roberson: I know that's Gavin.
I know.
I was joking.
It's now just a continuation joke.
Mark Gastineau.
[laughter]
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Wow, really?
Gastineau.
Eric Roberson: Happy birthday.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Gastineau.
Haven't heard that name in awhile.
Eric Roberson: Okay so let's--
let's keep it movin' let's --
This song is entitled
'Couldn't Hear Me over the Music'.
And this is the band once again
The Bomb Dot Com.
[cheering and applause]
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Right on.
[applause]
[drums and keyboard]
♪ (oh oh) ♪
Eric Roberson: Anybody got potato
chips and almonds? We don't.
(hey)
♪ (oh oh oh oh) ♪
♪ (oh oh) ♪
Eric Roberson: keys, keys.
♪ Ta ta te ta ♪
♪ By ay ♪
♪ Ba de da ♪
♪ Ta ta te ta ♪
♪ Ba daaaa ♪
♪ Ta ta te ta te ta ♪
♪ Ba de da de da ♪
♪ She was sittin' listenin' for hours.
(as I play guitar) ♪
♪ Oh sing my songs upon the radio ♪
♪ while she was in a car ♪
♪ She came to my shows ♪
♪ Her interest would grow ♪
♪ She knew every note ♪
♪ Each line that I wrote ♪
♪ Oh oh oh
Oh oh oh ♪
♪ Suddenly she fell in love.
(fell in love) ♪
♪ Until I met this lovely girl ♪
♪ Was attracted by her way
(attracted by her way) ♪
♪ What you give for some couples
to build for ♪
♪ Us it just took days ♪
♪ So as time went on
I wrote her more songs ♪
♪ Knowin' that song
was soon comin' on ♪
♪ Leavin' me in so much pain ♪
(you see)
♪ The show must go on unfortunately ♪
♪ I'm all alone ♪
♪ Up from my dreams ♪
♪ Ah ah ah ♪
♪ 'Cause she --
(couldn't hear me over the music) ♪
♪ She couldn't hear me over the music.
(over the music) ♪
♪ She couldn't hear me over the music
(couldn't hear me over the music) ♪
♪ She couldn't hear me over the music.
(She never really knew my song) ♪
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪
♪ Ta ta te ta ♪
♪ Ba da ♪
♪ Ba de da da de da ♪
♪ As time went on, she started to see
I was not Superman ♪
♪ (was not Superman) ♪
♪ I may have a gift for these words
but I'm no more than a man ♪
♪ My songs about joy ♪
♪ My songs about pain ♪
♪ She loved them the same
but to me she changed ♪
♪ Oh oh oh ♪
♪ Holding on just got so hard ♪
♪ I would be up in the studio ♪
♪ Some nights she slept alone
(nights she slept alone) ♪
♪ She'd get mad, filled with jealousy ♪
♪ 'cause I'm making love to these poems ♪
♪ Now when I do shows,
it seems she get steamed ♪
♪ As if I have flings with those girls
that scream out my name ♪
♪ When she used to just do the same ♪
♪ But oh ♪
♪ Show must go on unfortunately ♪
♪ I'm all alone ♪
♪ Up from my dreams ♪
♪ ('Cause she couldn't hear me
over the music) ♪
♪ She couldn't hear me over the--
(she couldn't hear me over the music) ♪
(couldn't hear me over the music) ♪
♪ She couldn't hear me over the--
(She never really knew my song)♪
♪ She never, never, never, know
(She couldn't hear me over the music) ♪
♪ She couldn't hear me over the
♪ She couldn't hear me over the music.
(Couldn't hear me over the music) ♪
♪ Couldn't hear me over the music
(Never really knew my song) ♪
♪ Never really knew my song ♪
♪ She couldn't hear me over the music.
(couldn't hear me over the music) ♪
♪ She couldn't hear me
over the music, no. ♪
♪ (the music) ♪
♪ Eh, eh, eh, eh
(she never really knew my song) ♪
♪ but if you can't hear me
over my music ♪
♪ See sometimes you need
to turn down the music ♪
♪ yeah ♪
♪ If they can't hear ya over your music ♪
♪ no they will never, never,
never know your song ♪
♪ She may never
(she may never) ♪
♪ maybe never no, no, no, no, no ♪
♪ know my song
(know my song) ♪
♪ know my song.
♪ know my song
(know my song) ♪
See, when I was young, I wanted
all the ladies to know I could sing.
You know what I'm sayin'?
Figured it would help me out
with the ladies.
D. Maurice "DMo" Macklin: Yeah.
Eric Roberson: Ah you know.
And we would leave a party
or a function or whatever.
We would end up showin' up at White Castles
or Checkers or Chik-fil-A or McDonalds.
And there'd be women in there.
And I'm like, "Yes this is my chance.
I'm gonna get somebody tonight!"
"Oh you wanna take my order, sure."
♪ Let me get a quarter-pounder
with cheese and ketchup, ♪
♪ nine piece nuggets ♪
♪ value meal ♪
♪ super size ♪
♪ with a Sprite over ice. ♪
♪ Can I get a m-, m-, m- ♪
♪ m-, m-, m-, m- ♪
♪ McDonalds cookies, girl? ♪
♪ Yeah. ♪
Oh excuse me [laughs].
Oh yeah I can sing.
What's your name?
Foquanda. [laughter]
Oh gotcha.
Um.
♪ But then you wonder why, ♪
♪ a year later, ♪
♪ Foquanda doesn't hold me. ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ then you wonder why, ♪
♪ a year later, ♪
♪ Foquanda doesn't know me.
See. ♪
♪ See music doesn't have to
be music for you. ♪
♪ It can be your car,
(be your car) ♪
♪ how big your rims are ♪
♪ Music can be the way
you make them laugh ♪
♪ or reprogram any computer
that you have. ♪
♪ It's easy, you see.
Oh. ♪
♪ If they can't hear you over your music, ♪
♪hey, ♪
♪ I challenge you to turn down your music. ♪
♪ (music hey) ♪
♪ If they can't hear you over your music, ♪
♪ see, ♪
♪ they will never, never,
never know your song. ♪
♪ She may never
(she may never) ♪
♪ he may never
(he may never) ♪
♪ they may never know, know,
know, know, know know, ♪
♪ know your song
(know your song) ♪
♪ Google. Thank you for knowin' my song. ♪♪
[applause]
Eric Roberson; My name's Eric Roberson,
once again.
Aaron Hardin on keys.
"DMo" Macklin on background vocals.
Eric "Rain Man" Gaston on percussion.
Featuring Claudia.
My name's Eric Roberson.
God bless once again.
Thank you once again, Ryan.
We really appreciate y'all havin' me here.
Thank you.
And Pamela, for the beautiful tour.
00:56:56.967,00:00:00.000